hello and welcome to this video let's
get hot it with some games um what can
we do you plus two
right
so was a quick one inning
airing against some guy or five so I
went in for Ange I'm going to going to
play something different maybe
we I normally play them or night Scotch
but
why not something in hard you have to
basically invent it invent the really
Abbott
you
at c5
eight but
don't know this line
well
ermand
and on castling anything goes a six bush
or g3
maybe Queens X yeah I just wondered
about this is attacking Geum
problem
you
bit of a problem
you
you know good
you
I just did a maybe um he has some ideas
like c5 and Bishop
it looks a bit scary
you
please stop they don't know
and time again that this is useful to
know some stuff in any case let's see
what happened
warehouse
you
castle
I did chicks at age six seemed to me
but no him
you
as still I could have played f3 f3 would
have been useful anyway
but it and this is a useful move also 8
and X the pond
so we'll Queen
strayed distribution
main point of this queen sortie was to
get off the D file
a super annoying I think he already has
missed um something
I'm continuation that
okay it's definitely okay but but maybe
even more
have to catch up a bit
I'm
[Music]
by doing it Mike
at some some adjustment
okay I changed something now I please
let me know if the sound of the first
five minutes was better or this one
would be interesting to know
right now into the life is our going to
overlook 97 right and realizing of the
you
neide f1
I don't mind this is probably roughly
for this ending after I am um didn't
play the opening all that well I'm okay
with this
[Music]
maybe who won TouchWiz
okay now I can take play okay seven
Tess
you
much
you
yeah speed up a little bit have
increment though it's not
Casta claim
virgins
we're clear it could be behind so much
then it gets too hectic
okay so I wanted this egg the pawn
in time ready
[Music]
or whatever you ending on what he does
for example now be five books in check
knowing
I thought so
at all
you
you
now you can actually also check
and one stone
you
this is frozen
inside of me and I get and create a
passive
you
as pond should
the be enter the f-pawn
you
when define young so I think I had some
issues they are in the opening I was
definitely not that great I'm probably
you take away the Queen yeah I don't
know I kind of invented this as I went
along and Bishop g5 is definitely a bad
idea in g6 seems like of them but the
computer doesn't really agree initially
but we'll see Queen to f6
oh I thought he could take on g2 I mean
okay I'm castling queenside funny enough
this is fantastic from okay you know
what is going on here I can actually if
he cancels yeah I can't play 96
in love
okay so this wasn't so bad I thought
there would be something here for him so
this I paid this back and was long I
can't cancel and I did not see at all
that this movers I rented in 96 which is
a huge threat
okay
so this was a lame move then at age six
young
it wasn't so bad um if he takes our
ticket in
and it takes here a thought I can play
something slow or Queen a5 an a5 is
probably strong it's very strong
actually he doesn't ever move so he went
back now Queen f4 that was not good at
sea i DeForest so simply
I'm playing for an attack having Queen
a5 in mine
but okay Queen f4 but we had this and
now black ass okay yeah yeah
yeah I was you know I kind of thought
that I got away with the dodgy position
the opening I was okay with having this
producer and somehow this turned out to
be yeah yeah quite quite okay for me
okay one maybe I'm
and here I think I'm just a little bit
better
I this is probably fail but then you
went with this b5
I was
you
so I should go see phones yeah
you
into things also
yeah yeah it was
so I
don't
[Music]
you
okay so you're just staying here
so because I'm not really threatening to
take on g5 and either I'm through f5 so
this could be a draw man this is crazy
and and so if this is a draw
why is this not a true
was I managed I know in this position
have to manage
I've okay
if I've in order to play later g4 f4 f5
they get the passer or a very very
outside
so I'm a general point of ug5 wouldn't
be right
of you something and this wins as well
probably the most precise because here
if I get here
I'm just going to win no matter what
because he's running running out of even
here he's running out
now we ask okay I want to analyze that
long but was interesting so
you
bitte
so what else can I do
maybe a car oh I just I'm just I'm sure
something else usually I'm playing the
stuff that I have studied for my vasila
repertoire I just know these things
right well after I've written
and to forget it but
why I prefer to to play those remember
it's games in particular you need
s times and you come up with some
reasonable
this is generally used
okay so out of this caro-kann exchange
got something like something that I
would call cards but rupture burst
let's put structure usually coming from
this gambit
blind exchange variation
yeah
some same kind of structure with
the worst colors I could could have
played a 5a beef or the minority tech
but it wasn't certain I've maybe ESB on
it is sometimes an idea to first bring
the night to c4
put some pressure here and only then
play a 5 into B or as this makes a white
or a little bit more difficult
it's a tough call and in a blitz game
you just have to
come up with it I'm a little bit
surprised that white has not played
native yet
like most
[Music]
our obvious way to play okay there's
certainly odds
okay I'm going 95
it takes p5f
X
you
a bee maybe he can play Bishop b5 Queen
b6 and then the mute and the movie form
just actually a point and do
I was just thinking okay a six at some
point but you can just take that
but Bishop b5 Queen b6 before a6 you can
simply take
okay so this means you should complete
take on B this is not a bad it's pretty
justified
this would have been interesting to take
the pond
you will gain for nuclear opposition
maybe he just has in mind to play on the
kingside from it go and imagine or
happening now fy5 for example would be
good
you
they'll have lots of time our plate
quite quick
but with increment
can sometimes make those longer
I'm investment you shook Amos Lee said
if there is increment there is a good
time trouble not really so great and
imitating him but what I'm getting at
if
of a drastic decision but right okay if
I take a beat or now he might have it f7
I have to watch out for night f7
but there is nothing particularly wrong
about a key
simply claiming that every good on
structure okay I could play work before
but then route takes
we takes Knight takes Emily's
I already have a very very good bone
structure though I absolutely don't mind
if I simply do this
ask his rook away probably look a seven
this one came
every baby
okay
but before is hanging yeah
I think
abt
no Queen before 1917
king of it okay seven
[Music]
you
learn to play
you
I miss
you
was just
wanted to cover have seven
right
ah because I'm overloaded
played like in half a second
okay
okay
you
X
down
oak
two white got completely outplayed but I
definitely overlooked something
but ensure whatever
you
twenty-eight probably would have won
but that might win as well
1:10
you
no I couldn't prevent it
[Music]
now that it's a pain I mean justice this
is just losing her wage probably not
losing SS so on
if all looks completely ridiculous in
mind but it's not it's not losing
somehow so I take it he takes take so
the first one is I cannot take before
this is clear because 9 f7 is hitting me
or alternatively you can take her some
be even that is a that's a problem it's
not directly lost but it's not good
I'd be six and now I'm in trouble all
night b6 is wrong then but how can a
four be a good move in this booth this
is crazy
it's a best move
yeah yeah he thought I mean black should
be strategically better
but not a small margin but it doesn't
seem to be the case of the computer
thing equal and a-four happens to be the
best move which I find it crazy cuz
white is killing structure totally and
he just just a purely technical
consideration when it does work based on
night f7 and so on they're just hanging
by a thread but it does his work yeah I
now b5 or and he played this instantly
more or less a perfect game and why haha
every team once
six
you
Kenard
books you want as a queen d8 is much
easier but if you play perfectly you
play perfectly yeah we all know what's
going on but let's play the next game
you
so tallix
going back to my
you
this is a
very good line for white
nothing
decisive but I always liked this
situation with the night only
is some position
committed you
um the knight on c3 which can be a
pretty substantial difference the knight
on D 2 is covering c-4 reliably
in German black often has a big um
burden yet to carry with this I donate
five ever having good German
good position after remember to
I submit the cheating form in before
I just don't believe those games now
he's taking random things when they're
normal moves and so on and then all of a
sudden it has a bunch of perfect moves I
know this hey this rarely happens that
people have those odd that everything is
happening at once yeah like what time
management and the weird strategic
decisions and then all of a sudden they
play like they have a chip implanted
you
most a group c1 you know these are
indicators
because he had a simple win with with
the check on the aid and rookie 7 and so
this is what a human would play it wins
it's easy to see it do it right they
don't play
Audino per class
okay so let's focus on this game
it's just what it is you have you have
those clowns
every server
you
sometimes I get get remarks I'm in the
comment section
using somebody of cheating
exactly one single time one single time
and I would a cheating request and I got
a message from an admin back on the ICC
that I just played a world-class player
and northern engine confirmed that was
very strongly played but he knew that it
was yeah somebody way up there was the
only more cheating
just it just happens
have some pretty strong indicators
now here this position is nice for white
again it's all about offside night I
have a central advantage it's very
difficult for actual drum up some
counter play
now my idea was at you
[Music]
in question five
yeah just
no good way or the night on beat Aaron
and now it's hanging
resigned okay
so um yeah that was not not much to
check him not much we can briefly look
at this I think that when we are here
exbest line is take and how to play d5
this is basically a whole chapter in my
belief when white or takes and now you
can recapture plane i reaiize
imagine
um 96 and it's not terrible but their
position after d5 is I think favorable
and because you never really know what
to do it's also something that scores
very heavily I am yeah and in the game
before you blunder just to show um yeah
the engine is already on plus three
which is enormous but it's not totally
off because when these pieces are not
defending the King I'm coming with is
six ninety five and so on it's very Dean
ok so let's go for them maybe one more
game
[Music]
102 games
you
we'll be Vaughn we it's a cool name
right
is wonder how you can have a only has
two M's
how do we have like 2600 blitz and 1700
bullet but um it's possible because if
you only have two bullet games
if he would have 200 yeah
a new zone
[Music]
like
this is what we have in our names oh
goes in brother
we a new bearish or the i-85 was a pre
move not sure that I would want to make
but it's playable let's say
it takes a pretty strange
and now I can do a couple
something with capturing xfw aim
this wonder defy me I just wonder what
the right timing
is for
you
yes played a youth
you
okay
is
yeah Bishop e6 normal I just wonder if
he exit is Bishop g5
[Music]
in the annoying
[Music]
you
maybe I take first
eggs
should you either can't we eat then
you
you
so X or my plan anyway yeah
actually five still looks like a
dangerous move but I didn't quite see
what I could do about
the thing I have to play g6 which is not
what I want to do
[Music]
only thing that a bit of a consolation
is that
the inside situation is good
LightSquared
um traded
you're doing now reddening whoopsie wand
out of the sub list but this is an
important tempo
what about Stokes book see one book see
one Queen g5 Queen a6 I'd or
buttons knighted made
it can take with thee
and take with the fu
you
that's funny then just
tactical resources it also means that
I'm probably and know I can still have
rooks upon so Queen age three and what
cannot take on may donate seven but
Queen age three okayed was there which
is not a bad move
you
thirty-six Quincy to M
but you can move the Queen way
[Music]
you
that's what evil
hanging a comedy queen
what else is there
what about kind of a session is
you
I play to cheaters
weird
the tins this is the tits statistically
weird you know cause they don't play so
many cheaters why is this a cheat but
that is a completely [ __ ] opening
nobody would like that
III and then eggs makes no sense and
then he played perfectly
oh um either top chrétien point
x5 of course will aid
ninety-five
eggs now this is very important he has
to go queen III this is by far the
strongest because there is this tactic
and this doesn't work because here yeah
yeah yeah
Yas Queen f1 it's just about holding
otherwise this would work over in Queen
d3i 8 now 19 poison Oh
hex is the best move 5 will be the best
move
probably doesn't matter here everything
yes it's just a weird game
yeah I just it's very hard to believe
that like they played perfectly more or
less and still they will play a
ridiculous old thing like this would be
trolling yes but you also have those
weird incidents where here the bishop
takes he for takes like seven seconds or
something like and you can check this he
takes you for I took 40 seconds and why
it took seven seconds or this recapture
um you don't see it here because I have
this really differently set up but you
see the move times there was not a
single move by wide ever yeah besides
the move 583 that was only taking 1.5
seconds but every other move was more
than four seconds there times Bongo
typical was like five we have like five
seconds eight seconds 13 he takes d4 was
13 seconds here which is a decision
Knight g5 is possible heck the computers
going Bongo move yeah I just it's just a
weird game I mean
as I said in Hindi came before I have a
pretty good track record
hauling running our cheetahs and the
game I don't believe don't believe it
somebody who has two thousand six
hundred bits we'd made this opening and
have this weird time spends in play I
don't I don't buy that
yeah I'm sorry this these videos are
kind of weird but it's just what it is
and yeah I'm going to we'll see what
happens I'm going to all those cheats
and see what happens the first one was
one but there was absolute sure
absolutely
absolute Odisha and this one is like a
ninety percent call but I would be also
reasonably stuff only this guy is
playing him
[Music]
and Fisher and then not
okay anyway I'm going to do one more
game
or deform
and
[Music]
we won't have that in each sheet
you
I just had to edge
Londyn
you
as falling into a row
there's something that maybe somebody
should a stick it's because this is a
structure I had that earlier
[Music]
looks but something that Magnus plays
tremendously successful II really really
remarkable how good he scores on the
white side of the structure
tons of games and rapid blitz enter
classical
I'm also quite happy now night is really
nice
you
Bishop yeah this this is a movie I can
Tiki seven you just take that and
pulling him horn he his queen
or squares with weighted
you
it's just
I don't have a really hot key but it
isn't
[Music]
just have to make sure that you take
c-5m
be annoying his pawn has to do two jobs
but he takes e5 D takes the knight
you
okay this was not a cheetah okay okay
I'm going to wrap this video up you can
discuss about my call of the two
possible cheats the first one is a 100%
I don't really that's nothing that I
would argue about at all the second one
like a 90% call on mind I'm going to
report them and see what happens
okay thanks a lot for watching out was
interesting anyway bye why
you